wooden
this is what Magdeburg sounds like in
the songs of Stephan McNair
- guns man
be some happy
he loves both music and Magdeburg so he
called on the city's residents to tell
him about their favorite places they
inspired a CD featuring songs about his
hometown
hello hello my name's Stephanie Sh'ma
and I'm a child of Magdeburg something
that I'm very proud of but to where I am
in the world I know I'll always come
back to this city on the Elbe I'm going
to show you exactly why right now come
on comet Stefan's first recommendation
is right in the heart of Magdeburg after
the Cathedral it's the most famous point
of interest in the city
the green Citadel is the most colorful
and interesting building in Magdeburg
every window door and room is unique
the building was completed in 2005 and
contains 55 apartments a few shops and a
hotel and it's a tourist magnet that's
this is the highest point of the green
citadel it's a wonderful splash of color
in the cityscape of Magdeburg it was the
last building designed by Friedensreich
Hundertwasser somehow it's possible to
experience equal measures of both calm
and excitement here I really like it
there are guided tours through the
fascinating world of wounded fascist
architecture every day we proceed on
foot through the twelve hundred year old
State Capitol past the Opera House and
make our way to the Waltons a ship lifts
the historical locks are a technical
masterpiece they connect the middle and
canal with the Elbe River and flag to
Berg's Harbor
built in 1938 the ship lift allows
vessels to traverse a difference in
elevation of about 16 meters basically
it's a huge elevator for lifting ships
up and down opens a ship lift is right
outside Magdeburg I like coming here for
two reasons first I deeply respect and
am amazed by the people who were able to
come up with this thing of steel and
water weighs tons and it goes up and
down like an elevator
incredibly it's powered just by water
the other reason is that I always came
here on holidays with my parents and my
brother Magdeburg is a very Green City
that's why our last tip takes us to a
waterfront park the Hawthorne Park
surrounded by the tributaries of the
Elbe River it's a popular destination
for day-trippers this is where the Elbe
River separates into the Elbe proper
which heads towards Hamburg and the old
Elbe which eventually Peters out it's
totally calm here sit and relax and
contemplate it's really nice and there's
a beautiful waterfall and a little lake
the adult MIT outlet it's a wonderful
place to go for a walk relax and fall in
love yep
under Velma next time you're in
Magdeburg just ask for me kima and I'll
show you the rest just